mercredi une réunion publique de
restitution des travaux sur les rythmes
de l'enfant était organisée à trappes
pour l'occasion un comité d'accueil
particulier attendait le maire devant
l'auditorium de musique et de danse
plusieurs centaines de manifestants
remontés contre la mise en place de la
semaine de quatre jours et demi dans les
écoles de la commune dès 2013
à l'intérieur le climat étrange dans le
public quelques parents soucieux
d'obtenir des réponses sur
l'organisation à anticiper pour la
rentrée et surtout une majorité de
protestataires venus revendiquer
certaines décisions prises selon le soin
concertation
ce qui nous gêne le plus c'est que la
philosophie de cette refondation s'était
proposé des activités de recevoir une
subvention de l'état pour que les
enfants puissent s'ouvrir à autre chose
et que dans le dos qui proposait par le
mr bah oui pour la subvention puisqu'ils
votent pour 2013 et aucun moment il ya
des propositions qui sont faites pour
les enfants ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'on ait le temps de discuter qu'on ait
le temps de se concerter tous ensemble
autour d'une table et qu'on prenne les
décisions en rom en russie tout en
remettant l'enfant au centre des débats
et non pas
uniquement des points techniques ou
financiers la fcpe locale qui sur ce
dossier apparaît divisée absolument
regrettable que les enseignants n'ai
rien voulu entendre moi personnellement
je me sens pas du tout représentés par
des gens qui sifflent comme ça et qui
refuse le débat d'une certaine façon
puisqu'il n'était pas non plus présent
lors de la consultation
après cinq minutes de présentation des
travaux de la consultation par un agent
municipal le maire décide de mettre fin
à la réunion
l'important c'est qu'est ce qu'on
construit pour les enfants et nous avons
nous sommes en train de construire pour
la ville quelque chose d'intéressant
prison qui va jusqu'à mettre beaucoup
d'argent à investir un plan de 50
modification des écoles et assurer la
formation des éducateurs
la réunion ne sera pas reportée quant à
la réforme elle est maintenu à la
rentrée prochaine pour un coût estimé
annuellement entre 500 et 600 mille
euros pour la municipalité 36 écoles et
4200 élèves sont concernés